اذا نبدا عبد الصمد مع التوتر الذي يشوب
العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه في اعقاب
التغييرات القضائيه في اسرائيل فقط ضد
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه قلق
من التطورات الحاصله في اسرائيل واكد ان
الرئيس بايدن الدفاع
يحثان قاده في اسرائيل على ايجاد تسويه له
خفض تصعيد واستعاده الهدوء وفي الجانب
الاسرائيلي اوردت صحيفه اسرائيل لها وزير
الخارجيه
ليلى محادثه هاتفيه مع نظيره الامريكي بعد
اتصاله الليله الماضيه مع السنه الامريكيه
لينزي دراهم
من رئيس الحكومه بنيامين ان الرساله التي
تريد اسرائيل بهذا الحراك ارسالها هي ان
الحوار بين الطرفين قائم ولكن الحكومه
ملتزمه بتمرير الاصلاح الذي ترى انه سيعزز
طابع الديمقراطيه للبلاد نبدا اذا من كلام
المتحدث باسم الفانتاغان
الذي اعرب عن قلقي وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
من التطورات الجاريه في اسرائيل الهدوء
لدينا بعض المخاوف بشان التطورات الحاصله
في اسرائيل قد سمعتم ان قادتنا بمن فيهم
الرئيس بايدن ووزير الدفاع استون يحثون
القاده الاسرائيليين على ايجاد تسويه في
سبيل خفض تصعيد الموقف واستعاده الهدوء
نعتقد ان هذا هو افضل طريق لاسرائيل للمضي
قدما الاستق